first president's post-presidential life
find full schedule information online at
booktv.org or consult your program guide
my name is kathy mccormack and i'm board
president of prop memorial library in
old greenwich connecticut thank you so
much for joining us for tonight's
program
with local author jim campbell about his
new book madoff
talks
which has received glowing reviews from
fortune magazine the guardian and many
others i want to also thank the members
of the prop memorial library association
whose generous contributions make
programs like these possible if you're
not a member please consider joining
details can be found on our website
propmemoriallibrary.org
i also want to take this time to thank
jess reed and craig jones from greenwich
point marketing they've helped us all
year long with our zoom programming and
without their help we would have never
been able to stay so connected to the
community so thank you again to grinch
point marketing for all your help
um
copies of jim's book are also available
um on our website
propmemorial.library.org and also um
through diane's books and greenwich we
put a link to both of those um in the
chat
um
what else do we have to say this program
will be recorded and we'll send a link
um to the recording um in our follow-up
email and jim has also graciously um
agreed to answer questions
so you can use the um
raise your hand function
in the bottom right of your screen and
we will let you
ask your question at the end of jim's
talk
and so now it's my honor to introduce
local resident jim campbell jim is the
host of the nationally syndicated radio
show business talk and friends friends
of talk with jim campbell he's the
assistant news director of 1490 wgch and
is known for his hard-hitting interviews
of leading figures from the worlds of
business politics and sports
known for first campbell snagged the
first executive interview with the
former new york governor eliot spitzer
after his resignation
in the first interview with tycho ceo
dennis kowslowski after his release from
prison and the first broadcast interview
with former soccer analyst rumi khan a
government informant in one of the
biggest insider training
bus in american history
thank you jim for joining us welcome
thank you it's my honor and i see some
people i recognize up there so i'm
particularly happy folks are coming out
on a wednesday night even if it means
just going to your living room i want to
i got to thank louisa green first
because she is so nice to me and
she jumped on and invited me the minute
the book was coming out does so much for
the town of greenwich on the board of
the library the boy scouts etc kathy for
inviting me kevin mccarthy director of
the library for inviting me jessica reed
for the technical support we even had a
rehearsal last week she's so efficient
so um i'm honored to do this and i think
people are
are going to be stunned at how little
they know about the madoff story despite
the fact that the general perception is
it was one guy operating behind a
curtain who pulled off a big uh ponzi
scheme and actually he was enabled over
40 years by all kinds of
of ways from co-conspirators who i call
his big four which are his major
investors who actually bailed him out on
occasion and came to have the power to
extort him
um the willfully blind conspirators
which was the hedge funds that fed all
that money into him and knew something
was up
what i call the unwitting conspirators
the sec and civic who uh scc had five
investigations they missed on
and um the witless co-conspirators his
high school graduates he hired in the
17th floor of the lipstick building two
floors under his legitimate business
with top-notch uh business school
graduates so this has been kind of a
whirlwind let me give you uh my first
question i always have to answer is we
had nothing to do with the timing of
bernie's uh death that uh i was coming
home from the wgch having been up since
4 30 in the morning and doing the
morning news show and at the
intersection of uh
sound beach and the post road
across my phone it goes you know bernie
madoff passes away and i was a couple
hundred yards from the shell station
there i was going to stop and get a
snack
my phone starts exploding and texts and
phone calls i get to the snap place and
i'm told that i'm on bloomberg uh radio
in 10 minutes and that they'd already
announced it on their website so i had
to go
sprinting home to do a seven minute
interview with um bloomberg that they
knew about before i did and then i got
the uh the new york post called and
asked me to write this is the middle of
interviews now the new york post asked
me to write a 2 000 word article in the
afternoon for the next day's paper that
the editor said he would tease on the
front page if i would get it done
and i'm like trying to figure how do you
write 2 000 words um
you know in a short time span but he was
good to his word the next day was on
like page five or six i got out of bed i
looked at the new york post mobile app
and it was the number one trending uh
article
at the time
then i got some more of the uh tabloid
type calls the daily
mail of london called me and asked me if
i knew who was getting the body of uh
from the bureau of prisons
and
i turned that you are kidding me you are
so you're not asking me that question
and um
no they weren't kidding and i said well
i can't answer that question i don't
know and then i got some other bizarre
uh ones and a picture that was in one of
the articles of the numeric express bill
you may have seen it and it shows ruth
madoff charging 57 000
in one month on the corporate credit
card was a private firm it did not mean
she knew about a ponzi scheme but it was
kind of like looking at the firm as a
piggy bank well anyway that got picked
up by one tabloid and then i saw it all
over the world all these forward
articles that would come in i'd
recognize 57 000 and jim campbell i
couldn't recognize it in another word it
was all some foreign language whether
it's french spanish and on and on so i
kind of learned not one of those
tabloids called me to find out it was
just 57 000 was all across um the world
so now we'll go back to 2011. how did
this thing ever happen uh
i'm nobody they don't know who i am the
madoff family and all of a sudden you
know bernie's talking to me for what
turned out to be eight years
and i i was uh taping a radio show that
was actually going to be live and the
day before the the author who had worked
with the family on a book said that um
andrew madoff would talk to me off the
record
and um so i called him and i right away
jumped all over him you know i said your
father gave you 2.2 million dollars to
buy a co-op in the last uh months before
this went down shouldn't you be giving
that money back right away
and then he stunned me by saying
absolutely and he seemed very open and
answered any question i wanted to
and then i um so said the show's on
tomorrow he said well you say it's live
i'm going to listen and if you say the
same thing i want to make sure that you
do so he listened
and the second coincidence uh which
everybody knows around here old
greenwich ruth was moving uh
his mother from florida to old granite
so i offered to take her out to dinner
to lunch
and so uh andy set it up at the beach
house it was uh in december there was no
one in the restaurant we got there she
arrived in sunglasses which she did not
take off even inside of the restaurant
for a while
uh then orders a chef's salad but she
proceeds to devour like she's not seeing
food and we ended up hitting it off she
was incredibly nice um good chemistry uh
we were walking out and i said you know
can i get a picture of us ruth she stops
and she goes you're wired aren't you she
thought i'd set her up
but once i convinced her that i was not
wired that it was a legit conversation
off the record uh she hooked me up with
bernie
and
i told her and it took about two weeks
for the prison assist email system to
approve us coming together
and so i told bernie bernie said andrew
and ruth have vouched for your sincerity
so i'm going to talk to you hopefully to
dispel the myths about this and the
misperceptions uh so he obviously was
going to try and uh
tell me his his version of uh reality
and uh ironically andrew
madoff on december 10th bernie confessed
the afternoon before he was arrested by
the fbi the minute bernie confessed
andrew never said another single word to
his father ever again
so when bernie vouched for andrew he was
either making that up or he was or ruth
had uh conveyed that
and
bernie and i go back and forth with
these beautifully
seven uh page handwritten exquisite
handwriting letters and as well as uh
emails once he had a stroke there and i
ended up with about 400 pages and that's
how we got to where we got i um
i told bernie at the end of that i got
to figure out what to do with all this
i've never written a book or anything
but there's got to be a book in here and
i got an agent we searched around for a
uh publisher and there was no interest i
got another agent and he sold it and
signed a contract with mcgraw-hill
inside of one week
and and so that's that's what started
and i told bernie i'm gonna vet every
single word you said and he said jim i
accept those conditions uh probably to
his regret but um that's what he did
so that leads us up to the story now and
um
i try to convey first off that this was
not an event that happened uh alone that
this would have been this could have
been stopped in five minutes in three
different ways at least that i have
uncovered of which it actually lasted
for 40 years
um which if you know anything about a
ponzi scheme they last for very short
durations and they inevitably have to
fail because you have to have more money
coming in the front door that is going
out the back door because there's no
real investment activity going on
some investors money is being used to
other to give to other investors so
you've got to have more and more people
so that's why they have to fail
generally and um if not for all these uh
co-conspirators uh in the various ways i
address he would have been caught uh
relatively quickly another thing that
surprises people is that normally the
wizard behind um the curtain that in
this case bernie was on the 17th floor
of the lipstick building behind locked
doors that his own sons did not even
have access to and they ran the 19th
floor business which was 100
legitimate and ethical uh called the
market making business they did trades
for discount brokers customers working
for the firms like um schwab
so anyway uh bernie is uh is downstairs
there and he wasn't the guy that made
all the money a guy named jeff jeffrey
pickpower who was the biggest of the big
fours bernie called them took seven
billion dollars out of that hedge fund
that's nine times what bernie madoff
stole
to hide into the he took it and hid it
in the back door
of the
market making business when it was
having solvency problems plus the family
obviously took a lot of extra money out
when when you know ruth is charging 57
000 a month but this guy pig hower is
the guy that made all the money the
three other guys each made a billion or
two um
as well
the most unfathomable thing to me was
that
you would think logically that what
happened was bernie's running this very
legitimate business he's very highly
regarded much the regulators on wall
street he treats his customers with
great respect
and you would think well something bad
must have happened he must have lost
some money
and while it's not legal he says i'm
going to double down it's a gambler's
mistake do a little ponzi or something
to keep it alive we'll catch up pay off
whatever happened and then we'll be back
and no one will ever know what would
happen and bernie told me a story just
like that that he'd never told anybody
else
he he didn't even tell his lawyer this
story um and his lawyer ike sorkin um i
spoke to because bernie waved attorney
client privilege which is unusual uh as
you know
so i said oh okay bernie so at least
there's some logic even though you made
a huge mistake because it was criminal
go in and start vetting everything read
the forensic reports of the consultant i
talked to the fbi
bankruptcy trustee and lo and behold
bernie at the same time he was building
this successful business which became
the number three market maker from zero
broke the monopoly of the new york stock
exchange was building simultaneously the
biggest criminal enterprise in wall
street on the same uh in the same time
two floors down different types of
employees he hired each
for each he could he found honest
competent people and he found people he
could manipulate didn't understand what
he was doing and he ran them both so you
can imagine how compartmentalized his
mind was
the legitimate business was worth three
billion dollars in and of itself at pete
exclusive of any hedge fund
so you have to uh you have to go figure
so these big four guys um came to have
this power they could extort returns
from him um he grew to hate them
and in a sense this was a reverse robin
hood because he had a whole bunch of
what i would call average not high net
worth investors who were putting in
money all the time over 30 40 years and
they were of average wealth and they
built it up over time a ponzi scheme is
easy to detect by the way because all
you have to really ask is where's the
money
are you trading with anybody who are you
trading with
not much more than that where's the bank
account do you have an accountant and by
the way he had an accountant who was a
one-man uh band in a strip mall in new
city new york wasn't even legally
licensed to do big public accounting
um jp morgan is bank at one point said
somebody should call to find out if it's
a car wash or not and it turned out it
was a laundromat because he was
laundering money he was also invested
with bernie
so none of these simple ponzi tests were
done
and why is that
we'll go to the sec
they conducted five separate
investigations of bernie and never
uncovered the ponzi scheme never really
uncovered the 17th floor
never really figured out that they were
charging him with the same uh what they
expected was the same offense in each
investigation even after they cleared
him
the time before they thought he was
doing front running
and front running is when you're a
market maker jumping right in front of
your customer because if you know if
your customer is going to order ibm
that's a bullish signal right he knows
what the customer is going to do you
jump right in front of it you take a
little slice because you know the market
the market's going to go up that's how
they thought he was able to guarantee
results because he was cheating and he
knew what was going on and he was
jumping right in front of his own
customers the funny thing was bernie
never once ever did front running never
once would have done that to his uh
customers and um we can talk about robin
hood if anybody's uh heard of that
because they have abused their customers
in a way that bernie
would never have
so
as the sec misses investigation after
investigation
there are some whistleblowers harry
marcopoulos you probably know of
we're looking at this starting
in the late 90s
didn't understand harry and they didn't
want to listen to him they thought he
was disgruntled competitor
but
to give you some examples here here is a
way that the sec could have solved it in
five minutes bernie in fact told me he
gave the sec his account number at the
depository trust company all you have to
know is that's a clearing and settlement
entity that all your trades have to go
through
and he gave them the account number
which was zero six four six
and the market making business every
trade could be traced there and finra
and the sec did that
no problem
so ernest gives him the number and he's
expecting them to ask okay we're calling
about his investment advisory business
we're told it's a sub account in the 646
account
and they would have found out in five
minutes there was no such sub account
there was no never any ia or investment
advisory or ponzi scheme trading ever
ever to go through the dtc
and guess what
sec didn't make the phone call
even after he gave him the information
um it's pretty amazing the
whistleblowers knew bernie's strategy
called a split strike conversion
sounded very complex i could never find
any of his victims or even the traders
on the legitimate floor upon 19 who
could explain it to me but you know what
which is what he designed it to be but
if you understood it conceptually it was
very simple
it should have mirrored the stock market
which means highly correlated which
means most of the time it should perform
as the stock market does
so the reason that harry marcos could
figure out within two hours was that
he found that was actually five percent
correlated it mirrored the market five
percent of the time in other words
it could not do anything that bernie had
said and by the way if it had mirrored
the market it couldn't have gone up
every month
bernie never had a negative month in you
know 20 or 30 years so his whole
strategy never made sense even if you
could understand it and no one uh
apparently did and the
sec
did not
so where did all this money come from
that was going into uh
bernie's hedge fund it was coming from
what it called feeder funds and these
are hedge funds whose job it is to say i
have louise's money this is she's very
conservative i'm going to look across
five or six portfolios and i'm going to
put her money exactly with what fits her
objectives
in other words i do a lot of due
diligence that i promised to luisa
before i take her money and she feel
comfortable with me and then she trusts
me to go put her money in there in
return for that um the hedge fund
charges its normal fees which everybody
in greenwich knows it's two percent of
assets 20 of uh the gains under this is
the hedge fund capital and the feeder
fund just takes one percent for due
diligence and
and helping do administrative work
these guys
what they ended up doing bernie did not
allow any due diligence which right off
the back would ask you why would the
hedge funds accept that
well maybe because bernie passed on all
those
lucrative fees that i just mentioned
back to the feeder funds
basically so they wouldn't ask any
questions
so he was basically taking money in
taking no fees for it other than
stealing it as a ponzi scheme and giving
hundreds and hundreds and actually
billions of dollars to the feeder funds
and what are really kickbacks uh if you
will
which they call fees and in return they
didn't ask any questions not only did
they not ask questions
bernie made each of them sign an
agreement that they had no discretion on
the investments
at the same time he told the sec that he
had no discretion on the investments the
feeder funds did and all he did was
execute trades
so you can see
you have the sec missing investigations
never having the right people they never
looked to investigate a ponzi scheme you
have the feeder funds pouring this money
and never asking bernie any questions um
so that um
that they would just get fees in return
for
taking people's money often not even
telling them they were putting it with
bernie's fund and often not telling them
that they were only with one fund all of
it with bernie they were supposed to be
diversified
i'll show you some slides in a bit that
show you how he pulled this off but he
had a small staff on the 17th floor
these were high school graduates
unsophisticated didn't understand wall
street and
they backdated every trade which means
the trades were all fake they didn't
realize it was totally illegal they
never realized it was a ponzi scheme in
40 years and just to show you how bernie
knew how how to hire his administrative
assistant who was a good source of mine
on the legitimate floor she's a hundred
percent honest he paid her 125 000 a
year with no ira
her equivalent job on the 17th floor she
did all the phony training for pickpower
for instance who would dictate his own
returns
her last year bernie paid her 670 000
salary and she had a 58 million dollar
ira
had the same job basically uh as eleanor
so you can probably understand why she
didn't talk nor does she ever figure it
out because
all of her money was in the firm when it
went down
so she obviously didn't know it was a uh
it was a ponzi scheme
thing is blown up now um all these folks
have lost money they lost 19.5 billion
they'd invest that they thought
based on their financial statements they
had 65 billion dollars so you turned to
sipping what is civic the securities
investor protection corporation it's the
equivalent of the fdic
the fdic has been around since the new
deal and has never failed to pay the
money that it says it owes up to that
limit to any investor ever and never
cost the u.s government a dollar
civic on the other hand
did not tell people certainly these
innocent victims that they didn't intend
to cover a ponzi scheme they said if
there's uh this there's no real
investment activity so we can't cover it
and uh furthermore since the gains are
fake we're not going to recognize your
final statement we're going to recognize
only the original investment value
so imagine oh you're you're a merrill
lynch client opening up your statement
and finding out that number isn't real
and furthermore that the sipc doesn't
really intend to cover it
and furthermore they didn't have enough
money to cover it
they've been told 16 years ago uh before
the uh bernie went down that by the gao
that they lacked enough money to handle
a major uh wall street brokerage crafts
and bernie's firm only had 230 people in
it
so what did cipic do
that one dime of the payments to the
madoff victims came out of the civic
fund
instead they went to madoff victims
remember everybody lost their money at
the end
any madoff victim that had withdrawn
more money than he put in over the years
they went after the clawback money
any madoff investor that left more money
in other words hadn't taken it out they
were to get that money
and they basically raised 14 billion
dollars uh that way taking it from one
set of
made off investors and giving it to
another set
never struck me as very fair it was
legally uh
case law uh supported that
but um
a lot of victims
not only had money clawed back that they
had lost even though over the 30 years
they may have taken out more they may
have had no money left they
had their homes gone after they had
their iras gone after the average age of
a madoff victim was 75 years old and
some of them had to go back and work in
walmarts
and um and things like that and and in
my opinion if the sec failed five times
and civic didn't have the money on hand
uh really honestly to pay them back
why shouldn't these have investors been
considered out since the government
basically had cleared bernie as legit at
the same time this was going on the
tarp program uh was putting 800 billion
dollars into wall street firms exact
same time to keep them alive while the
madoff victims uh went down and went
through court proceedings for years over
money uh that had been clawed back
now there's one other area that also
totally missed this um
ponzi scheme and that's his bank jp
morgan
the only entity anywhere that actually
could see into bernie's account and see
what how much money was really there
bernie told me that he never had more
than 5.9 billion dollars on deposit at
what was called the 703 account at jp
morgan the last three digits
um the rest was supposed to be in the
market or
it was fake ponzi money and jp morgan
didn't even clearly understand that it
was for the investment advisory ponzi
business they thought it was a
legitimate market-making account
even though that account had been in
bank of uh new york for 30 years
and um
if you have a equity strategy which his
was is quite simple to say his bank
account has got to show payments for
trades counterparties and it's got to
show dividends coming through it there
should have been four billion dollars of
dividends that flowed through this
account and there should have been
payments to counterparties non-stop
instead 170 billion dollars flew through
that through that account 170 billion
there wasn't one dollar of dividend ever
deposited there wasn't one payment to a
counterparty ever made and jp morgan
never uncovered that
and that's only one of the three things
that jp morgan screwed up [ __ ] i have
to tell you it's kind of painful i went
to tops with jamie dimon who's the ceo
of um jp morgan now and i gotta tell you
testament to his character i asked him
if i could come in and speak to the
people there even though jp morgan
completely screwed up and he let me do
it and just this week i i offered to
give him a book and i told him i would
not be insulted if he if he blew it off
and he that he wasn't going to like it
but he has taken the book
and at the same time this civic trustee
that i was just telling you about
his claim to fame is that they raised 14
billion back out of the 19 so he claims
to be the most successful ponzi scheme
uh retriever despite the fact that he
got the money from other madoff victims
he refused to see me three times
um because the truth is more complex
than he tries to uh parlay it at 14
billion he took 2 billion in fees and
expenses off the top of that um that
came out of the civic fund not the
madoff
uh victims but that's still two billion
bucks that could have gone uh in my mind
the bulk of it to um to the investors
that lost all their money
the um
the final things before i show you some
slides on this
this scheme in many ways
was also a fr tax fraud scheme
um there were two conspiracies in my
mind the government never pursued and
one was these biggest investors these
big four and the others were doing major
criminal tax fraud um pickhauer himself
was calling up and he would say i want
this game for x y and z go back dated
and then he'd call up during tax season
i need these tax law uh lost
to um you know uh
center offset the uh the gains no one
has ever been prosecuted criminally for
that none of the hedge fund um managers
who did the due diligence and humbled
the money in there without asking
questions have ever been penalized uh
criminally
the other thing was um
the international feeder funds and what
in particular you'll see her picture
later on
funneled incredible amounts of dirty
money in in other words they were doing
money laundering for russian oligarchs
eastern european oligarchs colombian
drug uh drug lord money um to the extent
that the colombians threatened jp morgan
when jp morgan was trying to take money
out of a madoff uh hedge fund this again
the government decided never to go after
these folks and um i mean it's a little
dangerous to go after these guys on the
other hand it was um grossly illegal
bernie said to me he didn't even know
who was in the international you know
coming in through the through the banks
and and feeders um
over there
um i'll talk briefly about reforms and
then i'll show you um
um
some slides and you can uh you know
shoot questions at me the first thing
that when i started there i had 30
reforms at the end the first thing was
that individuals and i tried to say that
individuals need to think like a doctor
in terms of that hippocratic oath do no
harm first nobody understood what bernie
was doing
secondly bernie was telling people on
january 1st what their return was going
to be anybody that tells you they can
guarantee your market return in january
you should be running the opposite
direction from them
because it cannot be done
and thirdly sadly um you can't
necessarily necessarily assume the
government is going to be there for you
the sec did not find it
uh cipic did not have the funds to
reimburse people and did not feel they
were obligated to since it was a ponzi
scheme
and so you need to take responsibility
for your own investments in a sense you
need to be conservative you need to
understand it and my hero was warren
buffett the the market has gone up nine
percent a year for a hundred years
bernie was paying about 11 in the last
few years
buffett would say invest periodically
regularly in a low-cost index fund and i
would say take that nine percent and
sleep at night
yeah in the end hundreds hundreds of
people
should have gone to jail and literally
only a handful did from the 17th floor
and when bernie passed away it was the
last single person uh in prison for what
is the biggest ponzi scheme uh in
history
and if you'll let me now let me
let me show you now some some slides uh
when i did the cbs sunday morning uh
interview the uh
jim axelrod was a correspondent and he
found um
the these documents so compelling that
we just sat around the table and did uh
what was called the b-roll going through
these things we were going to walk
through old greenwich where i first had
uh lunch with ruth and ruth would go to
the bagel shop the upper crust bagel
shops we were gonna kind of do that kind
of thing and she would have walked at
the beach but he got so into the uh
documents so i i like to show them this
is the post article by the way that was
the 2000 words and what i thought was
great about the post he simply could not
accept any losses that is the
fundamental issue here with bernie he
psychically could not tolerate losing
money
so the legitimate business he was making
commission money right which means the
market's up the market's done he's
making his commission so he goes into
this investment advisory business and he
holy cow i don't make money on every
trade so he stopped trading and made it
up he could not live with it
and um they got that uh they put that
headline in there i thought that was a
a very good catch on their part
this is the uh lunch outside the little
pub with um ruth when we were leaving
and you'll notice she was comfortable
taking this picture unlike the first one
where she thought i was wired this was
after uh after after a couple of years
uh knowing her we would have regular
lunches and um and then a lot of text
messaging and emails and you know
she was
she lost 800 million dollars in net
worth she paid 100 million bucks to the
justice department they left her with
two and a half million dollars of which
500 000 of that went to lawyers and
she's the most resilient human being she
had no complaints about it with me she
she said i'm we're from queens we're
average people
i don't care i'm now driving a beat-up
car that was dangerous when it came
around uh corners she moved into into an
apartment eventually that she was paying
2 900 a month she had to turn in every
receipt to the bankruptcy trustee over a
hundred dollars
and she was just functioning
it was very estranged with bernie by
then having been cult-like devoted to
him and
also telling me frankly she was upset um
that he had uh that he had some affairs
that she found out about uh during this
whole process um they were dating since
they were 13 years old
this is andrew madoff who was of course
the first person on that and that's his
girlfriend catherine hooper
who um
is the person that you know let me into
the uh in access to a lot of people
and who told me that despite her belief
that she thought to the depth of her
soul she believed danver was innocent
but she told me says if you find it jim
i'll accept it which i thought was
pretty amazing and she was true to that
um she just sent me a letter a couple
days ago saying she loved the book and
she um
and
basically thanked me for pursuing the
truth
now this this is the uh this is what
freaks this of the cbs jim axelrod out
on that one side is the front page and
the end page from jim from regards
bernie that's the seven page space
letter that's the um
that's the first one which starts off
i'm going to go on my sons and wife's
recommendation
and these letters would come out
with just compulsion to rationalize his
behavior
on the other side is a one sentence
letter to andrew and catherine who you
just saw
and it says i'm so sorry dad not even
love dad but i'm so sorry that was his
confession to them or his apology i
should say
and that's what he could get out he
didn't know who the heck i was you know
i'm jim campbell and he's writing these
passionate you know seven page letters
and he could write his son only a one
sentence letter um saying i'm so sorry
so uh
that says a lot now here's what an
actual madoff statement looked like that
every month they would get this is an
actual victim from chappaqua actually
i'm not sorry from our mind and as
you'll see these are all legitimate big
cap stocks
um and a fidelity fund
um us treasury market uh treasury bills
and um
there was so much detail
that it snowed his uh investors every
single thing on this page is fake except
for um the name of the of the victim in
the name of the firm
they would come stuffed with con uh
trade confirmations he did tons of
trading they would come chronologically
in order
it gave the
victims a real sense of this guy so
ordered so structured and
remember he said he passed on all those
management fees because he was just
taking commissions he wasn't really
making the decisions he was just doing
the training but where that yellow box
is is where the commission is supposed
to be listed and you'll notice it's
empty
so some of the fakery uh he didn't quite
get
there were also
trade confirmations on dates and the
stock exchange was closed but people
hadn't didn't figure out there were also
confirmations with the prices that did
not match anywhere in the range of that
day's trading so there were ways to have
seen that it was fake
this is uh one way i talked about the
depository trust right he had uh which
is where everything has to clear so
everything's got to be there
he had a fake system that showed a live
feed
to the depository trust and if you'll
notice you can't see it closely but this
is for the date of uh november 30th it's
a
a security position um at that time
but the investigators found that this
was actually entered in the computer in
december
so
literally he was making up the live
screen showing positions for trades that
happened that he actually typed into the
system a month later
was how he did the laundering of money
out of the ponzi scheme into his uh
his his office and
the 703 account of jp morgan in this
example it took this is an actual
example
4.3 million out of it deposited into his
personal account at morgan stanley
once it was a personal account of morgan
stanley it went to the market-making
account which was at the bank of new
york which was the legitimate businesses
uh bank account and then it went into
the back door of the
uh
market making business hidden in the
trading profit and loss statements
and this was profound because there was
800 million dollars of what looked like
trading losses until this money was
pumped in
well who ran the trading desks andrew
and mark madoff
so it was very
on the surface incriminating that how
could they not have known that bernie's
fudged all this money through their 800
million bucks is a lot of money
and i was able to find literally the one
person in the firm
that saw the actual p l's before bernie
fudged them that could vouch for whether
mark and andrew have seen it and this
story is in chapter eight
um it's real touch and ghost story it's
uh um
i think you'll get a kick out about
reading and i also go through whether
ruth um knew or not and how she was
what were the question marks there i'm
the first guy that made a determination
on the family's complicity on knowledge
of the ponzi scheme
now this was what bernie called and i'm
not jewish right my yiddish is about the
stup account file
and this is what what what would happen
bernie would promise you uh
in this case it's 18 for the year
so we're in november and as fake trading
has you up for about nine percent so all
of a sudden he's got to get you in one
month to 18
um
the literal translation of uh a stump is
to push up it's slang for sexual
intercourse and what he was doing was
in the file was putting whatever would
took take in trades to push up to that
18
which means he might have to have show
100 percent gains through the stoop file
to get louise's 18
uh that he promised and this was this
was uh going on for for decades
these are the actual ibm uh
as400s that were out of date in 1980
that he was using to run the 65 billion
dollar
scam i took these pictures the fbi
turned them back to the forensic
consulting firm and they were locked in
the closet
and uh they let me go in the closet and
take pictures of uh of this machine just
think 65 billion dollars this machine uh
all it did was print out fake stuff
um
there's the spreadsheet that harry
markopoulos figured out everything was
fake in two hours on the right which is
interesting
is um
there is a fund
that copied the no that was actually
identical to madoff's called gateway
it's a mutual fund
and that blue line represents the actual
results from bernie's strategy if you
did it legitimate
that red line is bernie's fake green if
you notice it's straight up
no investment line looks like that and
you know whose line that really is that
is the new york mets sterling equities
made off uh results uh because they had
their account with him
and
they had
483 accounts with bernie and that's
that's what theirs looked like over this
time period bernie's went up 48
the actual uh
other one went down 20 and they were the
same strategy so you could have seen
just by looking at a publicly available
mutual fund
it could not have been done
this is the infamous american express uh
charge that ruth charged 57 000 on that
month there's all kinds of names of
folks in the family who did not work at
the firm who were basically using the
firm as a piggy bank the great irony is
this is bernie's card as he as the
holder of it and he was charging zero
dollars on it
but everybody else was uh jumping into
it
now remember i mentioned that uh
accountant in the uh one-man strip ball
well bernie had all of his tax stamps
and stationery in his warehouse uh out
on long island because bernie did his
own taxes
so it was they found all the equipment
and that's the guy's name
also found in in the warehouse was all
these lottery tickets and nobody knows
what these were for but to me these
represent bernie's desperation trying to
figure out how to get out of it because
he told me
that at the end jim he was hoping there
would be a nuclear attack on wall street
so that it would wipe out all of his
records
that's how he was thinking that's how
stressed so i wouldn't be surprised if
he was buying lottery tickets at the
same time to try to figure out how to
get out of it
now this is uh the international money
laundering story this is sonya cohen
she ran the
she ran the money laundering theater
fund she owned a bank called bank medici
in austria that was basically taking
money out of this russia to cyprus to
her bank and then into bernie
and the scary thing is is sonja looks
like bernie we call her the evil soul
mate um and she's also never been um uh
criminally charged or anything but she
has been um
she had a lot of money clawed back from
her fun
now this is how this is how i ended i
dedicated the book to my father who i
say gave me the moral foundation that
bernie madoff so sorely lacked and what
i tie this back to is eleanor spoleri
who i mentioned earlier was his
legitimate uh honest secretary
and she was friends with all the folks
down there they came up at the same time
they grew with the firm and she said
that me that she used to be absolutely
tortured
what made some people go one way on the
path and some the other way
and
in the end this thing is no more than a
morality tale
and a tragic one uh that is you know
mark committed suicide andrew died of
cancer um
and um there were other suicides uh as
well
and
to get right down to it you know
the decision to take that path even
bernie had two paths right he had
legitimate and the illegitimate so it's
uh it's really it's really a tremendous
story and i hope that gave you um
i hope that gave you a little bit of a
flavor of it um as as we've said the
diane's books has the book there because
i think you'll find it a fun read and i
think you'll get the message that
that i try to get across with this
wasn't one man's scheme this was a
failure of the system and he was enabled
to get this done
and you may be stuck with more of me
because uh netflix is uh bidding on my
book and i'm supposed to hear literally
later tonight or tomorrow so you may see
this on netflix but yeah thank you that
would be kind of exciting um
for a guy who's never written a book so
i have a face for radio so hopefully you
won't see me
now does anybody want to shoot questions
at me
jim we have two questions
in the um chat actually to start with
um luisa asks who says a question for
jim and this is during your presentation
why do you think these investors didn't
analyze their statements i find this
statement for the person in our month
fascinating why do people continue to be
swindled by these ponzi kings
yeah you know um i would ask the victims
if they went through their statements
and
often they did and or because they look
so official um i know some that went
through every single every single
statement because these confirms there
might be 50 60 in one month
but the other thing is that this was an
affinity crime is 85 jewish on jewish
charities and
this whole network was communicating and
going in i interviewed uh i talked with
jeff matthews today he was a hedge fund
he ran he was from greenwich he ran a
hedge fund for 23 years you know what he
told me today
he's one of the most honest people i've
ever met
he told me he had 80 investors over
those 23 years and in those 23 years
precisely one investor asked him what he
was doing
none of the others did it was all his
reputation
bernie had a pristine reputation and he
was called the jewish team bill he was
as secure as the u.s government he would
deliver no matter what
and um
it was a con
and uh
now that how does that excuse the feeder
funds because to me that's the real
question these guys were being paid to
be experts and to promise to louisa they
had done that they'd ask the questions
they verified it and by the way bernie
did not allow any independent custodian
that's something that you should always
check on because an independent
custodian has the assets so they're
there they know the trading is there
they can't be hidden bernie wouldn't
allow that for obvious reasons and never
did
um so
people want to also
believe it there were a lot of people
who knew something was not right but you
know what
maybe he's doing a little front running
maybe i'm going to look the other way
he's our crook
happens all over wall street you know
let's let's just uh look the other
direction and then there were more that
knew he was lying didn't know it was a
ponzi scheme and those guys in my mind
are you know are complicit uh in that
sense
but i come back to where
you got to ask those questions you got
to understand the strategy if you can't
understand it in about two seconds
something's wrong
and um he designed it that way every he
he admitted to me he would try to
explain stuff so no one can understand
it and the funny thing was the strategy
was completely conceptually easy and he
couldn't do what he said it could do
and nobody seen it nobody seemed to get
it not even the sec
by the way the sec has a group in
washington that does that they do they
look at investment returns and results
they figured out in a couple of hours
about the same time harry did that it um
it could it couldn't work the way bernie
was saying and
the message never got back to the
examination team on the ground because
the sec was so poorly coordinated nobody
spoke to each other the branches didn't
even talk to each other so uh they that
never got that message never never got
back along with the failure to call the
dtc for five minutes
i hope i answered that louise that's
kind of long-winded maybe
jim uh next question from sandy is
bottom line you explain what he did but
why
good question
um
you
know i think i think um
psychologically when i when i talked
about the the
once you accept that he didn't do it
because he got in trouble and that he
made a mistake and that he took the
wrong path because he lacked the courage
morally to get out of it that he did him
at the same time that's when it becomes
you know
so hard to understand so obviously he
has tremendous powers of psychological
compartmentalization
which by the way he had no insight into
the prison shrink had to tell
kind of apparent doesn't it and um
so when he was successful in the market
making business making commissions and
then he could not accept losing money on
the other side
he didn't know what to do and this is
where he lacks remorse in his mind in
his mind
he was pressured relentlessly by greedy
investors
they wanted returns returns returns
always positive
was up he had to deliver
he gave his sons millions of dollars to
buy homes when he had no cash because he
couldn't say no to his sons it could not
become apparent that he couldn't deliver
anything
he saw himself as a victim of his of his
investors particularly the big four's
greed
he said to me jim
i am a product of the corrupt culture of
wall street and if you've never managed
the high net worth person's um
assets you won't know what i'm talking
about these guys cheat they don't pay
their taxes their money's offshore
and all this was was
deflecting responsibility he could not
take responsibility
for basically anything it was always
someone else's fault and it was always
pushed on to somebody else
when he says these were greedy investors
and everything who was the person
telling him what the returns were who
was the person making up the return who
was the person giving them everything
they wanted who was the person that
bribed the feeder funds
bernie
jim carl asks do you think his biggest
individual investor carl shapiro
knew what bernie was doing or suspected
anything
well first off jeffrey pighour was his
biggest carl shapiro was one of the big
four
they obviously knew he was short cash at
periodic times because they bailed him
out
um it's not likely they knew it was a
ponzi scheme because they left their
money in there too although when you
look under the hood they did a pretty
good job of not having much there when
it ended um
but uh
i think that they were completely
complicit in the tax fraud um as i said
the coward called in his own own results
as he wanted he actually dictated his
own capital gains um but the smallest of
the big four guy named stanley chase um
he never
not only did he not understand the
strategy he said don't tell me i don't
want to know what it is but you may not
lose any of my money so you know and uh
and bernie never did
um
jim luisa asks did bernie ever talk
about his prison experience how did he
adjust after living such an incredible
lifestyle
you know we didn't end up talking much
about that because of the fact that um
the assumption was i'd come down there
at some point and then the warden kept
vetoing it so we didn't get around to it
i will say that um
barney has a charisma um not a gordon
gecko charisma but more of like a
grandfatherly uh and he knows how to
bring people in and i think they thought
he was cool there because he pulled off
this incredible thing
and so i think he was doing he was doing
all right he followed everything about
the case that all the court cases
you look at the stuff he gave me it was
um
unbelievable memory recall he was
reading all the transcripts um so he was
he was staying very plugged in and um
he had his he had his story and he stuck
to it he would admit to me the ponzi
scheme and the stuff that he criminally
admitted he wouldn't admit anything else
he would never admit that it started one
day before 1992 ever
and um he stuck to that story and you
know of course it looks to me like it
was going on since the early 70s so um
he could never come clean really and i
don't know that he ever came clean uh to
it to himself and uh again he thought he
built a legitimate business and he
thought that he wasn't given enough
credit uh credit for that and uh
his investors he at one point told me he
says you know anybody that thinks
they're going to earn twice the uh
treasury bill rate should know there's a
lot of risk there so they should have
known and jim i warned him there was
fraud that there was a risk of fraud in
these kinds of investments too
imagine the goal i'm telling you that
what's their fault that they i there
could have been fraud why didn't they
find it
it's hard to believe it it's stranger
than fiction and also i don't know if
this is conveyed but
most nobody knows this do they it's it's
largely untold
you know it's kind of good to get to get
to get the word out and put the whole
thing uh uh into into into perspective
i hope you hope i hope you do buy the
book and read it by the way too i have
to put a small pitch in for that and
diane's books is your independent
bookstore so you're supporting a local
uh greenwich firm and uh i have we have
book place so i can send anybody who
wants to sign uh a signed book plate and
uh and you're welcome to contact me with
any questions by the way or if you want
to talk directly or whatever and you can
ask as many more questions as you want
anybody else or
i don't know where jessica is
yeah i'm right here i actually have a
question jim
um i'm just curious if the investigation
and perhaps this book if if any of it
has led to any like reform or
policies or better investigations for
other
you know
that's a good question um
yes i've talked to harry marcos about
this because harry's the man that you
know basically first uncovered was a
ponzi scheme and the sec wouldn't talk
to him as i said after it all went down
the sec did talk to him and he says the
sec is very good now at detecting ponzi
schemes and and by the way there's they
come every month they just people are
doing ponzi schemes it's some kind of a
sickness i guess uh but they are very
good he said that if one happened
offshore remember we talked about all
this hidden money and the money coming
in if one was done offshore he thinks
there could be another bernie but that's
the only way
now
other reforms you know i i in the book
call for i talked to you about how sipik
and finra are both run or owned or
funded by the brokerage industry and i
think they should be made independent
like fit the fdic and they should be
properly capitalized and i don't think
that
um
investor
feeder funds hedge funds should be able
to say they do do due diligence just in
their marketing for sure i think there
should be some legal requirements so if
luis is giving her money she knows he
actually did follow these steps but the
assets do actually exist this is the
investment strategy he's following and
uh
and those kinds of uh those kinds of
things
the sec needs to become more of a
proactive cop what the sec people think
that's what the sec does no what the sec
does is come in after the mess is made
and try and clean it up
and i mentioned rob i don't know if you
guys know about robinhood but robin hood
is very hot right now it's an online
broker that says they give free trading
right well how do they give free trading
you know how they give free trading they
get they direct their trades to
exchanges um in return for getting a
rebate for sending them that business
right it's called payment for order flow
guests who invented payment for order
flow basically bernie madoff but bernie
did not screw his clients on price
robin hood was taking such a big rebate
that their customers were getting
inferior price execution
get this to the extent that they paid 34
million dollars that if they'd gone down
the street and paid a commission because
they were
robinhood was so greedy they were taking
so much money plus what did we say that
do no harm
you know invest in a low-cost mutual
fund
massive ongoing trading is dumb it's not
going to work and because i give you
free trading what are you going to do
you're going to sit in your basement and
trade
and so
you know to me the sec they did sanction
robin hood for that but the question is
robin hood is still making all their
money and payment for order flow
and is still trying to encourage their
uh investors to basically follow
everybody off a cliff because when you
make money in trading this is how it
happens all the time it happened to me
when i tried it younger you make some
money you think you're a genius right
you're not a genius the market was going
up so then you say i'm a genius i'm
going to go on margin now and borrow
money because this is so easy so i'm not
going to borrow money i know you know
what's going to happen i'm going to lose
all my gains and i'm going to lose all
my money because i was on margin i'm
forced to sell it
and that's what happens and um you find
out that you can't beat the market and
particularly when you're an individual
sitting in your basement who doesn't
have the access to information that the
wall street guys do
those are the kind of to me the jury
that
the
sec should be
protecting investors
doing more stuff up front force robin
hood to disclose exactly what free
trading really means and to disclose
that they're not screwing their
customers by giving them an inferior
price
quote so that they can stuff money in
their pocket
and these things really never seem to
totally uh totally go away
unfortunately
jim uh two more questions luisa asks
what have the undergraduate and graduate
business schools done regarding teaching
ethics and business did bernie impact
the way our future business leaders are
trained
uh what was the first part of that did
the is this is there going to be an
impact on business schools
um or uh an impact on uh teaching ethics
in business school
oh
you know
you know what made me laugh i'm doing a
a virtual zoom to the entire chota
alumni body um in june and a guy um who
was at chode asked if he could join the
panel because he did research with a
harvard professor who talked to bernie
sanders is an expert well guess what i
happen to talk to bernie about that
harvard professor he's a professor of
ethics in the business school at harvard
and he lied to bernie by taping his
calls without telling him
and
wrote in his book that bernie uh he
asked bernie about uh andrew's death
and he said that bernie
spoke about it for half a second and
then switch to interest rates and this
is an example of how
sociopathic bernie was so i asked bernie
about that and bernie said that first
off the guy told him it was it was an
interview about ethics not that it was
about directly the scheme not that he
was taping him either and also he said
jim i was on suicide watch for the
prison when andrew died so this guy's an
ethics professor
and i intend to pop this on this guy at
the choke thing which
i'm sure going to come as a bit of a
surprise but dennis um
kozlowski and jeff grant who you know
from greenwich probably a lot of you
this same professor um
interviewed them too because he was a
book on white collar criminals both of
them had major problems with his ethics
i found the guy to be nice i interviewed
him on my show
um
but uh can you teach ethics in business
school you should be able to it needs to
be ingrained in the culture of the
school and in the course uh in the
entire course though not just one course
that looks like they're you know trying
to stuff it i went to
business school of dartmouth and it's a
very small school and it is very
culturally focused on team play and
doing the right thing and not
backstabbing each other and all that
kind of stuff i can't speak for some of
the other schools um you know who i'm
talking about
and jim it looks like this is our final
question from sandy
did you find your entire experience
surreal
you know uh
somebody
i think jim axelrod or somebody asked me
that like
first off what all of a sudden and this
i have
i've never been able to fathom this i
find myself in 2011 suddenly emailing
the most vilified criminal in the entire
planet
and that's that just it to this it
boggles me to this day and the other
thing there's a recent thing is it is
you know that katherine uh hooper andy
ruth and bernie all trusted me with
their legacies none of whom knew me and
knew anything of me and knew that i was
going to pursue the truth
um so it is time and it is totally
surreal first off the whole you heard me
get total luck getting to bernie right
total fortuitous luck that bernie dies
right before the book comes out and i'm
on cbs with six planned viewers
and now netflix is interested in this
thing the netflix director told me that
if i go with him we i this documentary
will be seen by a hundred million people
in 28 days
i mean
it's totally surreal the the guys the
director who's the top director for the
true documentaries is saying jim my
people say i have to get your book and
i'm sitting here saying
something's wrong here i'm a first-time
author and this top director is
basically begging me to give you know to
work with him shouldn't it be the other
way around shouldn't i be like
you know begging the guy so it is it is
surreal um
and you know i do hope though my dream
was more than any of this other stuff
was that this would be the definitive
account of this story and that the true
untold story and the failure of the
system failure all of that would come
out because it hasn't come out and um
you know i think fortunately this set
will end up being it in part because um
madoff has passed away so there's going
to be nobody else that's going to be
able to get into that
that side of the equation
and nobody else has tried to tackle the
other stuff so hopefully um hopefully
this book will sit as that one one of my
idols is bethany mclean who wrote the
book on enron called the smartest guys
in the room
and that book um is like and peter
elkind co-wrote that who's also a friend
bethany did a blurb for my book on the
back i wanted this to be sort of like
that and i can't pretend to be bethany
uh she's brilliant and written multiple
books but this was kind of my hope that
i might be like in the minor league you
know with her and that's what my hope is
thank you so much jim for joining us
we're so lucky that we got you before it
seems like you're going to be a very
busy man for a very long time with this
book oh i love this is all great it's my
hometown
well we're so lucky
i would do anything for louisa anything
from louisa anything incredible
thank you so much and we hope that
someday we're going to be able to host
you in person at the library thank you
everyone for joining us good night thank
you everybody for coming out take care
[Music]